ladies and avis laissés sur internet
laissent pantois le praticien il est
tantôt qualifié d'excellent tantôt de
méprisants et négligent toujours est il
que ce gynécologue tourangeau ferait
aujourd'hui l'objet de plainte devant le
conseil de l'ordre en cause de présumées
violences gynécologique qu'il dément
samuel colin
fin février la façade de son cabinet et
tagué par un collectif féministe sans
suite de multiples témoignages une bonne
trentaine au moins sur le compte
instagram du collectif la même chose sur
des groupes de discussion tourangeau
ainsi que les avis récoltés par google
sur ce médecin gynécologue
certains sont positifs mais la plupart
des patientes alerte il m'a insérer le
spéculum sans prévenir j'étais forcément
contracté alors il m'a tapé sur la
cuisse comme si j'étais un cheval en me
disant on se détend à l'est c'est la
première fois qu'un médecin gynécologue
me crie dessus
de mon côté il a effectué une
auscultation sans gants je n'y
retournerai jamais nous avons rencontré
une jeune femme suivi par le médecin
pendant presque dix ans une relation de
confiance secret jusqu il y a quelques
mois un courrier reçu va tout changer
elle est alors invité à réaliser des
examens approfondis après un dépistage
du cancer du col de l'utérus le
gynécologue refuse sans s'expliquer elle
finira par réaliser ces examens avec
plus d'un an de retard d'autant plus
qu'il était en mesure de le faire c'est
un examen un peu particulier mais lui en
tout cas avait le matériel pour pouvoir
l'effectuer et c'est ce que j'appelle
surtout de la négligence médicale et si
au final l'examen ne révèle pas de
cellules cancéreuses
reste un sentiment de mépris pour cette
autre tourangelle alors enceinte le
suivi sera encore plus problématique
elle le consulte après des contractions
importante à sept mois et demi de
grossesse il me prescrit du spasfon et
du repos en sortant j'ai décidé d'aller
aux urgences pour un autre avis après
une rapide auscultation c'est
l'effervescence je suis hospitalisée
trois semaines avec interdiction de me
lever le pire a été évité de justesse
sans ça j'aurais probablement accoucher
à domicile dans la nuit avec un bébé
prématuré qui aurait peu de chances de
s'en sortir contacté le gynécologue ne
souhaite pas s'exprimer
son avocat mark morin au niveau de sa
personnalité c'est peut-être quelqu'un
qui un franc-parler mais qui n'est en
aucun cas quelqu'un de malveillant si à
un moment donné on lui reproche une
faute précise et bien il est assuré pour
cela il lui incombe à la victime de
faire une procédure devant le tribunal
judiciaire pas de poursuites au pénal
mais il y aurait plusieurs plaintes
auprès du conseil de l'ordre des
médecins jugent du respect de la
déontologie des praticiens l'ordre ne
souhaite pas communiquer sur cette
information les condamnations peuvent
aller d'un avertissement à une radiation